hey Pat thanks for joining us good
thanks for having me how are you
we're doing great you know deep topic
today we were talking about kickers and
Jon Gruden said something last night
where Seton can you play that for Pat
and then we'll get his expertise on what
maybe Jon Gruden was trying to say so we
know it's a different football but are
the goalposts tighter in the NFL than
they are in college you know they're the
same size yeah they might be taller
because the NFL made that rule or they
got to be taller because guys were
kicking them over the upright in the
stripes we're having a tough time
calling it in or not but they're the
same size and poly some you go DM on
Twitter you just split into my DMS and
ask me if I think it's tougher in
college or the NFL to kick I'm assuming
that's where we're headed to yeah yeah
no I think I think physically Holly by
the way thanks for 5mins DM amy-jo good
this morning just woke up no lately from
a Tuesday being your face in there makes
you feel great but anyways I think
physically it's a lot harder in college
because the hash marks are wider so it's
a longer angle on a tic for the short
kicks you have a you don't have a
professional long snapper which is in
charge of the laces right so everybody
thinks because of a cinch for a pet
detective the Dan Molino was the one
that messed up the laces Finkle Einhorn
Finkle line on
but the lace is now on the long snapper
so their job is the professional staff
about the same location for the laces
are out every time the holder now it is
his job to place the ball down and what
the wrong link admits a kick in college
you don't have professional doing that
you got guys that I'll probably do it
once or twice a week that they're not
really practicing so from a wider hash
marks to the unprofessional long snapper
and holder it's definitely physically
harder in college I think this is me
personally but ticking is 90% mental and
when there's a lot of money on the line
for a lot of people including yourself a
little bit of a mental hurdle some time
for some guys to get over and then once
they figure it out they just keep it
moving
physically it's much harder in college
but when it comes to a mental side
whenever you're kicking through your
livelihood it's a little different some
guys it takes a little bit to get over
that explain why I've in Oteri's been
able to do this into his 40s
so Adam Vinatieri is classy incredibly
classy every time you detox he says all
the right things he never does anything
wrong he's a great husband a great
father but he's the most competitive
human walking on this earth I honestly
believe that I think whenever we go in
and lift if the quote Jackson inclines
benching like hundred and ten pound
dumbbells like sanitary wants to do it
too he just has this competitive nature
about him that he is just always proving
something when it comes to anything he
wants to be the best father the best
husband he's literally just the most
competitive dude I've ever met by life
two kickers now is there a need a do you
feel like you have to be more athletic
like you have to be more involved
because we have this label with kickers
that you know they're just kickers yeah
oh I think back in the day though the
people who were just kicking and just
punting it was kind of one of those jobs
where you could do it and not really be
that athletic oh granted I think the
notion of punting play like Dan you
could find a ball but you're gonna suck
at it right but you could probably slow
football pretty well I've seen you shoot
a basketball you're pretty good but you
can't you can't kick a ball for crap
yeah you know I don't know you don't
well I'm assuming you suck at it and
it's one of those things where you don't
have to be athletic to do it but what
we've learned is the more athletic you
are the more in tune you are with like
I'm trying to stay healthy you the
better you're gonna be and there's only
32 jobs so guys are trying to get an
edge and I think they're working out and
the specific training really came into
fruition here in the past couple like
maybe last decade or two where you see a
lot more athletic guys I'm granted I am
certainly the least athletic guy in the
Indianapolis Colts maybe maybe above
yeah there's probably a couple guys are
more athletic then but I think you have
to be an athlete to be good at it
I think that's any position you to be a
th creature any of those things yeah I
thought it to be good at it and your
average in almost 52 yards a punt this
year
yeah man we're getting a long talk we
did good stuff it's good stuff we're
talking to Pat McAfee punch her kick her
for the cold
have you heard paulie's Andrew Luck
impersonation no I heard Andrew hurted
oh I heard that yeah yeah lucky wasn't
upset was he no no okay what because it
was all over the net and you know
anytime you - Andrew the laugh or
something - Adam he's gone all the time
yeah it's gonna make its rounds around
Indianapolis and you guys made him laugh
so that's great okay here's Andrew when
he was on last month we didn't we didn't
shoot ourselves in the foot the positive
place I'm even even if drives didn't end
and touchdowns our field goals they
weren't ending in interceptions and
fumbles you know I just aha going to
London a couple days off really didn't
need them you know we got it together
the off until I step it up Stanford
football not doing good indie football
doing great McAfee bullying them how is
it you know what I'm gonna tell you what
Holly I think your your IQ is probably
good 60 to 100 points lower than Andrew
I think that's a Frank Caliendo type
impression there I think that's uh y'all
Pat is really the key to the special
team a finitary legend got him away from
New England Pat McAfee uh uh you know
he's good kid just a woman a media
career ahead of him like nobody's
business like every conversation with
Andrew you must use context clues to
figure out what the hell's going on
because he'll use a word or two that
you've never heard of one of those SAT
words back in the day so you're saying
I'm a linguist but I think you're really
onto something here hey congrats on the
season so far there at least for you
individually well yeah I think I think
the big thing here is Dan and you know
this because you've been around the NFL
oh you gotta win you gotta win to be
happy really I mean it's the world we
live in
it's we're also we work all year all
these we get a training camp I slept in
a dorm for three weeks I want the Canton
Ohio Soph Fiasco there we're talking you
dedicate a lot of time to this and the
only way you can truth be happy is if we
win so when it beaten the Bears which is
a good squad boy you're following a
little bit swinging a rock but I was
whenever we win it's much better and I
hope it keeps backing him there all
right good luck guys
Sunday night and in Houston any thank
you so much man I hope you guys have a
great day see them Villiers all right
after you guys I know it's Pat McAfee
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience